for saudi arabia blocking negotiations
what's your response sir
how are the negotiations going sir
how do you respond to accusations that
saudi arabia is blocking negotiations
everybody's saying that saudi arabia
they're the
i think
these are serious accusations about
saudi arabia's position
you must have your own comments
not serious allegations these are
fabricated allegations they are
fabricated allegations just allegations
publicly
so people are telling lies about you
absolutely
hannah um
tell us first the significance of those
difficult exchanges we just saw with the
saudi arabian minister
unusual to have such an inscript uh
unscripted encounter uh with the the
saudi arabian contingent and you saw how
physically difficult it was and how
reluctant he was to speak on the
accusations that saudi is trying to
derail this summit but eventually came
forward with the idea that those
accusations of fabrications and lies and
we've been told all along that these
last three or four days would contain
fireworks and i think that was an
opening salvo really an accusation of
acrimonious accusation about lies and
it's all hanging as these things often
do on this text this is the draft cover
agreement that came out in the earlier
hours of this morning and it's really
down to one paragraph where the big
fight is happening and that is around
timing at the moment the text says the
country should come back with better
ambitions enhanced ambitions
better plans to to reduce carbon
emissions by 2030 by the end of next
year now big developed nations like the
us and the uk and others are really
pushing for that as an absolutely
crucial element but big polluters like
china and saudi arabia are saying
absolutely not and i don't think it's an
exaggeration to say that at this stage
the view is if that paragraph survives
that new timing urging countries to come
back by the end of 2022 then cop 26 will
be able to say that it has kept 1.5
degrees of warming within reach if that
paragraph does not survive the next
three days of bruising negotiations and
they will be bruising then cop 26 will
have fallen short there are other
tussles going on about increasing
adaptation finance for poorer nations
and the inclusion of language around
fossil fuel subsidies and phasing out
coal but they're side shows really it's
paragraph 30 that matters and over the
coming days we'll see whether or not
that paragraph survives boris johnson
prime minister of course about to arrive
crack some heads together and urged
nations to come together to save the
planet that is what this summit is all
about